Avengers endgame counted by many as the
greatest MCU film of all time and
counted by many as the greatest film of
all time and it is now officially the
highest-grossing movie of all time as
well but now what many fans of the MCU
think that the feature is going to be a
little dull how do you top Avengers end
game how do you top the Infinity Saga
that was built up over the past 11 years
how do you top Iron Man Captain America
Thor the Hulk Ultron and probably the
biggest Thanos how's it going everybody
it's Warren and what if I told you that
the biggest moment that the MCU could
possibly have is not a Vineyards endgame
but is yet to come many people may not
think that it's possible because
Avengers in game was such a huge movie
it was the highest-grossing film of all
time and it had so many different
characters coming together and again
like I said with the reveal of phase 4 a
lot of fans aren't too excited about the
immediate future of the MCU
which of course is understandable
because avengers endgame wrapped up the
first 11 years of the MCU but today I'm
going to talk to you about why you
should be even more excited about the
future of the MCU then you have for the
first 11 years and if you think I'm
crazy stick with me until the end of the
video and see if I change your mind and
if you don't think I'm crazy you
probably already know where I'm going
with this there have been a lot of
reports and rumors going around recently
talking about the next big crossover
event for the next Avengers film and all
the rumors and reports say that phase 4
and phase 5 are leading up to one thing
Avengers secret Wars battle world one of
the biggest Marvel events that we've all
been waiting for and to top it all off
it could be the Reese Abroad's the
directors of Captain America the Winter
Soldier Captain America Civil War and
Avengers infinity war and Avengers and
game to come back and direct Secret Wars
but before we get started don't forget
about my giveaway I am giving away an
xbox one or a ps4 the winner gets to
choose all you have to do to enter the
giveaway is be subscribed to my channel
leave a like on this video and comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
down below I already give away one at
500,000 subscribers and I'm giving away
another at 550 also if you'd like a
chance to win
tendus which you can click the link down
below and follow me on twitter so the
Infinity Saga of the MC was always going
to be pretty nostalgic from here on out
because we were all here at the start of
it and although phase 4 is going to
introduce some new characters a lot of
people are pretty underwhelmed with it
because although we are getting some new
awesome characters we're only getting a
few during phase 4 the Black Widow movie
is going to introduce to us taskmaster
and red Guardian and although the movie
is set in the past we have no idea what
is going to happen to these characters
in the movie so they could very well
appear in the future of the MCU Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness is
supposed to introduce nightmare and they
very well could bring back to our Mamu
and Mordo as well then of course we are
getting introduced to shang-chi and also
in the movie should come the real
Mandarin something that Marvel fans have
been waiting for for a very long time
and know we are not counting the one
from Iron Man 3
I never thought people have been hurt
lied to me this is the Mandarin no it's
it's it's embarrassing hi Trevor Travis
metric d'etre I know I'm sure - in
person but small everyone says that but
um hey if you're here to arrest me
there's some people that like to roll on
in here's how it works now Street and
then we have the Eternals and a lot of
people aren't really that excited about
the Eternals because most people don't
really know who they are but remember
before the guardians of the galaxy movie
came out nobody really knew who they
were either and everybody ended up
falling in love with them
but we're going to beginning many
characters introduced to the MCU in the
internals including Black Knight who is
going to be played by Kit Harington and
then of course in the Hawkeye series
we're going to see him train Kate Bishop
and in Thor at love and thunder we are
going to get Jane Foster Thor so
although these are definitely exciting
new characters nobody really crazy is
being introduced at least none that have
been announced but phase four is
actually going to be very exciting that
Disney Plus shows are going to be really
great but that's sort of just a little
bit of bonus content
shang-chi and The Legend of the ten
rings Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness Thor love and thunder and the
Eternals are all going to be insane
movies and a lot of pee
are sleeping on the Eternals which is
kind of a good thing because when you go
see the movie you will be surprised they
have an absolutely star-studded cast and
the Eternals are great characters but
really what phase four is is a building
phase it's going to introduce new
characters and start rebuilding the MCU
from the very beginning just like the
infinity saga did - a very huge point in
time which will be the next Avengers
in-game movie and although we have no
idea what this movie is going to be
called in the future we do know that
everything is going to build up and will
most likely be a Secret Wars battle
world now if you are not excited about
battle world or you don't know what it
is you should be super excited because
this thing is essentially Avengers in
game on steroids there are a couple of
different versions of battle world but
it's essentially one of the biggest
events that Marvel has ever had and
bringing this into the MCU is inevitable
and is the way to top of vengers endgame
Avengers in game was just packed with a
ton of heroes and if you're skeptical
that nothing can top it this is where
I'm going to attempt to change your mind
Avengers in game was really really great
but there were a few things missing and
those things were the Fantastic Four the
Silver Surfer Doctor Doom Galactus and
the x-men all characters that could not
be in Avengers in game because they
could not be used in the MCU at that
point in time but now that Disney Foxx
deal is done and Marvel can use them in
the MCU and in the battle world event
most of these characters come together
the x-men get together with the
Fantastic Four and the Avengers so the
next Avengers in game type movie is
going to be a huge crossover event that
is going to have not only the Avengers
but the Fantastic Four and the x-men as
well so how do you top the heroes of
Avengers in game well you establish new
Avengers and then you throw in the
Fantastic Four and then you throw in the
x-men we're talking to Wolverine gambit
Cyclops
Magneto Professor X Jean Grey the
Phoenix force all these characters that
we have been dying to enter the MC will
finally be there and if you're wondering
how do you outdo a villain like Thanos
the Infinity Gauntlet well the answer is
you do two villains who are even more
powerful and that is Victor Von Doom or
Doctor Doom and the one and only
Galactus we recently heard a leak from a
credible source Mikey Sutton who says
that Doctor Doom and Galactus are going
to be the two main and big bad villains
of the future of the MCU now we've
recently heard reports that the MCU
moving forward is going to be divided
into two different parts we're going to
have the MCU storylines that take place
on earth and we're going to have a
cosmic MCU now the earth characters are
going to be characters such as Doctor
Strange Wanda vision black panther
shang-chi and of course spider-man if
the deal ends up working out and the
cosmic characters are going to be
characters such as Thor the guardians of
the galaxy and Captain Marvel Doctor
Doom is going to be the villain on a
grounded level or earth and Galactus
will be a cosmic villain and there will
be a huge battle world event where the
Avengers of the x-men and the Fantastic
Four will be fighting dr. doom and
Galactus both on earth and in space and
in battle world we don't just get Doctor
Doom we actually get God Emperor doom
now I know everybody is super excited
for Galactus to enter the MCU but God
Emperor doom is quite possibly the
greatest Marvel villain ever created the
battle world is made up of different
earths from different universes combined
into one planet and in secret Wars
battle world Doctor Doom literally is a
god he controls everything that happens
on the world he even makes Doctor
Strange who is arguably one of the
strongest Marvel characters basically
his pet there really is no topping
Doctor Doom and that's what the MCU is
headed towards not only god emperor doom
but also Galactus as well and as I
mentioned the Russo brothers once said
that the only movie that could probably
get them to return to direct a Marvel
film is Secret Wars and in a recent
interview the Russo brothers said that
they are sure they can find something to
do with Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios soon so the future of the
MCU is heading towards Secret Wars
battle world a huge crossover event
where we will see not only the Avengers
but the x-men the Fantastic Four and
characters such as God Emperor doom and
Galactus as well and not only will we
see these characters we will see
probably multiple versions of these
characters because battleworld has
multiple universes combined so we're
getting a movie that not only has the
x-men and the Fantastic Four with the
Avengers but will most likely see
multiple versions of different
characters that come from different
universes in this movie as well we could
even see a possible different version of
Tony Stark's show up so if you thought
Avengers in game could not be topped
wait till this event wait till Marvel
introduces the x-men the Fantastic Four
and the big bats as Doctor Doom and
Galactus have been stated when this
comes out Avengers in game may not be
your favorite MCU movie anymore because
although it may seem impossible to
believe this event is going to be much
bigger than Avengers in game so big
question right now if you are not
excited about the future of the MCU did
I change your mind does this get you
excited about the future of the MCU a
big crossover battleworld event be sure
to let me know how excited you would be
to see Avengers secret wars battle world
and see God Emperor doom and Galactus be
the main villains of the MCU be sure to
let me know in the comments down below
and again also don't forget to comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
like this video and subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and
if you're trying to win that Nintendo
switch be sure to follow me on Twitter
and click the link in the description
down below to enter as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof